you know a brand is what people think
about when they think about you
a brand is how people feel branding is
an experience
and so one of the things i think the
powerful things about a book
is people seeing youtube secrets seeing
the red cover seeing the whole
brand lift is it's kind of like number
one like your authority
but like the overall brand it's lifted
the perception
of video influencers my channel with
benji it's lifted the perception
of think media it's lifted the
perception of sean cannell the brand has
been strengthened
of sean cannell and this is sometimes
less trackable
but it's more important for longevity
if you want to impact people increase
sales get featured in media
and invited on podcasts and stages well
then you my friend should consider
writing a book in today's episode sean
breaks down 10 lessons that he learned
from writing the book youtube secrets
he's pulling back the curtain and
sharing some little-known secrets that
he learned
as well as sharing all of the details
about how much he made
and how this book has helped grow his
influence my name is heather torres and
you are listening to the think marketing
podcast the number one podcast that
helps you grow your influence online
and then turn that influence into a high
profit and high
impact youtube online business well in
this episode sean is going to be diving
into what he's learned from youtube
secrets and this episode is brought to
you by start startyourbook.live the free
workshop that helps you go from blank
page to published author in 90 days
with chandler bolt from self-publishing
school i'll tell you more about that at
the end of today's episode but let's
jump into
today's featured content
[Music]
so i'm so excited to dive into the
untold story
of writing the book youtube secrets and
share
10 reasons why i think you should
consider
writing a book and lessons i've learned
from writing a best-selling book it's
been quite a journey and you know it all
started
really back in 2015 when i was on a
plane ride
from las vegas to seattle to meet up
with my friend
benji we both had a background in
youtube he had done channels related to
real estate him and his wife
had a vlog channel he had a cooking
channel i'd been helping people
build their youtube channels i was kind
of behind the scenes doing video seo and
i'd been experimenting
on all kinds of different videos i
already started earning money with
affiliate marketing and different income
streams just kind of dabbling but like
had those income flows so saw all the
opportunity
that was happening on youtube and we had
this idea that we would
just kind of co-write a book and share a
message with the world little did we
know
that it was going to take multiple years
that we'd end up interviewing
around 100 people whose stories and
information went into the book and that
the book would become
the number one bestselling youtube
strategy book in the world
it was uh just crazy and i learned a ton
of lessons
but it actually all started with making
a decision to write
the book i mean we really didn't really
know that there was going to be
challenges ahead
of course is going to be challenging we
didn't really necessarily know
everything that would go into it or some
of the delays or challenges or obstacles
around the way
but we did plant our flag and make a
decision to write a book and the reason
i did that kind of initially was just
because
i had mentors and people around me
telling me the power
of writing a book how it'll boost your
authority how it'll position you
and so i made a decision and that's kind
of what it starts with i'm going to give
you some
reasons and some lessons that i've
learned um
but i just kind of made a decision not
sure not really knowing every
detail that was going to come in the
future but we went all in
and now the results have been absolutely
remarkable
and so here are just kind of 10 lessons
and i'll tell a few more details of the
story as we go
but this is kind of why i wanted to
write a book in lessons that we learned
the first one is authority
you know being a published author
elevates your positioning
in the market and what was interesting
was even in
2015 2016 when we just had youtube
secrets as an
idea youtube was already 11 years old
and yet there was
actually no books on youtube now to be
clear
there was probably 50 ebooks maybe 100
ebooks like if you go to amazon there's
always going to be like a whole bunch of
ebooks on whatever topic
but you can kind of tell that they're
sort of sketchy you know they're 33
pages long
there's like one and a half stars
someone's like this was full of
misspellings and didn't make sense
and so when i say there was no books out
there was really like no
quality books on the market yet a few
have come out since then
but the authority and maybe in your
niche you know you think well there's a
ton of books on my subject and i think
that's okay
but nevertheless by writing a book on
youtube
knowing that i wanted to help people
with youtube that had already been
teaching video and help
people with cameras and learning how to
do video ranking and affiliate marketing
i just realized that being a published
author elevates
your authority and positions you in the
market going into it
i actually knew that was the case but i
had no idea how true that would be
it's been amazing to experience the
elevation of my personal authority and
my brand
i think another thing is credibility it
sets you apart
in your field as a leader and an expert
you know it's not easy to write a book
it's worth it but it's not easy so when
you do
you join the ranks of those who have
overcome the obstacles
with discipline and perseverance i'm
sure a lot of books have been
been started they've never been finished
once you get your book
out there once you actually hold it in
your hands you've got that credibility
and then one of my favorites is it
really gives you a powerful hook
in your introduction like if you're
introducing yourself at
a networking event in person you could
say you know hey what is it you do you
go well you know i help people with
youtube i'm the author
of uh you know the number one
bestselling youtube strategy book in the
world youtube secrets i mean you may
kind of like try to
play it but you're just like yeah you
know i wrote a book and by summing up i
wrote a book
called youtube secrets like that alone
sort of a self-explanatory
of your authority of your positioning
and then in the beginning of videos a
lot of times i'll open up videos and say
hey sean here best-selling author of
youtube secrets and
founder of think media and so authority
um you know the book has become a number
one
best-selling amazon seller and in full
transparency we hit number one in some
pretty big categories and i believe we
cracked the top 100 when we launched the
book but you can become a number one
best-selling amazon seller
really easy like you just categorize
your book in like marketing
web development microsoft word microsoft
word tools
and next thing you know you put your
book out sell like 10 copies and you'll
be number one in that category at least
for five minutes
and i'm kind of joking but like to
become a number one
amazon seller is actually within reach
of a lot of people and again that
becomes an authority piece
and so that is one reason to consider
writing a book number two
mastery of my topic committing
to the uphill climb of writing a book
forced me to level up and it has
improved my content
and my videos have improved see when you
commit to writing a book you go there's
a lot of ideas going on in my head
but as soon as you sit down you go okay
wait a minute
like i'm not sure how clear my thoughts
really were if you think about i really
need to teach this now step by step or
break this down step by step
you go oh there's a little there's a few
gaps here so writing a book
it requires research it requires you to
refine your ideas
and actually in the process once we
committed we realized this would be
stronger
by starting an interview show and at the
time benji and i started a show called
video influencers and we
every week we would release an interview
with an expert but here's what happened
we learned so much from interviewing a
hundred experts
that were like entrepreneurs doing
youtube or creators doing youtube
and all of that went into the book as a
side benefit by the way
we built our network and all these
relationships with those people as well
all those connections and it blew up our
network
so even just that was really powerful
but mastery
of my topic once i
committed to helping people build their
influence with youtube
i wanted to learn as much as i could
about the topic so the process of
committing to write a book and that's
why i want to encourage you to really
consider writing one
is it's going to make you stronger it's
going to force you to level up it's
going to force
you to understand your topic better it's
going to help you be a better coach
educator encourager it's gonna give you
more
mastery of your topic
in our inner circle program we have ten
steps for building a six to seven figure
media empire and step number one
is claim and master your topic
you could start a youtube channel around
your topic that's good you post 10
videos there a little more authority 100
videos there more authority you write a
book
and you get that book distributed well
meaning on amazon audiobook ebook and
it's really you know professional and
you put it out there
you've really claimed and mastered your
topic at a whole nother level
and the other thing is it boosts your
confidence i mean when you've written a
book
like a real book right you're legit like
you're a bona fide offer
you're like man i got a book like i'm a
published author
and that positions you and helps you
master your topic at a whole nother
level number three
is you really get to impact people in a
deeper way i love this
because of course people are going to
buy your book they might just leave it
on the stand
nightstand you know they might read a
quarter of it which is significant
even that is good impact but a lot of
people are going to read your entire
book
and in a world where we are reading
headlines
reading tweets watching 15 second tick
tocks
and instagram reels and a world where
we're switching from show to show and
video to video
and our atten intention spans are
shortening the thing i love about
books is depth you get to unpack a topic
you get to have
deeper impact by really massaging
subject matter in such a way that it can
be more transformational
than just short form social media
and i really believe that writing a book
is service like you
listening to this right now have
knowledge and experience that can help
others
so i believe you have a moral obligation
to share it and writing a book is a
great way to get it out there and reach
people
and what's also been amazing is because
we put our book out
on physical book and ebook the ebook
is very easy to distribute around the
world via amazon
through all kinds of different countries
so we've collected money from not just
the us but also the british pound
european countries
japan india canada brazil
mexico australia we've sold ebooks in
all of those places
and i want to encourage you and i'll
share some resources or you can always
check out the training we're doing with
my
friend chandler you know at start your
book.live
but like this is so powerful because
this isn't super hard to do especially
when you have someone just walking you
through the steps and you'll learn that
on that training
like it's not super hard to do but
amazon gives us the distribution
to get your life-changing message your
knowledge and experience in people's
hands or on their ipads or their kindle
readers or their phones
around the world making a deeper impact
and what's also been crazy and this is
just some of the results and some of the
story a lot of people don't know
that youtube secrets has now been
translated into vietnamese
chinese south korean russian portuguese
and also
into the ukraine and what's crazy about
that
is that uh each of those deals are
additional deals where we've earned
more money where we actually get like an
advance and then we get
uh a portion of those sales once that
advance has been met in sales in those
local countries so we didn't really know
that youtube secrets was going to blow
we wanted to be as big as possible we
did a lot of marketing strategies which
is a topic for another day
but we definitely have now seen
that when you put your heart into it you
put your work into it you work with
smart people
you put out a great book that actually
it has the chance number three
to impact people in a deeper way and now
it's impacting people in other languages
people that i wouldn't maybe be able to
communicate with
in the language i speak english are
being transformed
because i made the courageous decision
to commit
to writing a book number four revenue
revenue now here's the principle you
need to know
if you haven't ever looked into writing
a book before or a business book or a
book as an entrepreneur
you usually never write a book to
generate revenue
the the mission of a book is exposure
awareness
you might break even you might go
negative like because it can lead to
other business opportunities or other
positioning and that's what most people
would say
especially too if you try to get
traditionally published up front you
probably won't make much money what
you'll get is the prestige
you'll get the distribution the
publisher and you may make a dollar or
two per book and whatever
advance you can negotiate however
self-publishing a book can actually
be a lot more lucrative than people
realize
and i realize these are some big numbers
but imagine if you just had a percentage
of this
success so for youtube secrets we have
sold over
40 000 copies we're coming up on 41 000
copies of the paperback in the e-book
the paperback's done about 22 000 the
e-book's done about
19 000. and check out the total revenue
we've
kept and collected right ebook a
percentage goes to
amazon like 30 goes to amazon paperback
it's via amazon create space because we
are self-published
is through uh it's like you get like
seven bucks
on a fifteen dollar book there's their
cut plus the cut of the book itself and
shipping whatever else
but out of forty thousand forty one 000
books sold
ebook and paperbacks we have collected
150
000.89 so far and the book continues to
sell
so most people say oh don't write book
to generate revenue and we've generated
a ton of revenue past that but that's
some serious money
and that is between 2018 and 2021 so
that's over about
three years it's about 50 000
per year just from the book
the ebook and the paperback book and
later we'll talk about audiobooks as
well as other ways to monetize as well
but number four
generating revenue especially when
you're self-published because you get
higher percentages and more money will
be left in your pocket
here's the thing you get your book out
this year it can sell next year
it gets so next year and you can create
another income stream
in your business your small business
your youtube business
which brings us to number five which is
create
leverage now leverage is one of my
favorite things if you haven't
really heard the term before leverage
means you do something today and that
pays you tomorrow i remember back i read
a book called rich dad poor dad
and he said when you invest in real
estate you create leverage like you buy
the real estate once
if somebody rents it from you you get
paid every month and it's going up in
appreciation
and you don't have to work on that like
go to a job and trade time for money
that real estate is working for you
while you're working at your job
that's leverage your book is leverage
you write it once but guess what you
keep on selling it
you clarify your idea again you put in
that work to clarify your frameworks
figure out your material
figure out the data and the research in
it but you get to keep teaching it
now every time you speak or communicate
or get on video or do a training or go
on a podcast
you you've you've you've galvanized your
message i went on a run a sprint
when we released youtube secrets and i
probably went on over 100 podcasts
i just said yes to every podcast i got
on some big ones i got on some like
someone was like they have you know 10
listeners i'm like yeah i just went and
i wanted to actually get better at
communicating so part of that was
practice
but now i had all of the messaging i had
used and clarified in the book
that i was able to just keep teaching it
and keep teaching it
because it was strong that was leverage
material
when you put the effort into writing a
book that means you have a lot of
material that you could use in other
ebooks blog posts
articles podcasts videos infographics
so why should a youtube content creator
sean why should somebody who's digital
doing video
write a book because it's going to give
you content material
for content marketing that can also help
you
generate leads get more subscribers get
people on your email list
it can lead to future opportunities
write the book once
future doors continue to open future
people i'm getting dms right now from
somebody else that wants to translate it
into another language somebody else that
wants to have me on their podcast
and like oh hey i would love for you to
come on and talk about youtube i saw you
wrote a book they may have just
discovered it and even leverage with
building our team
like all things being equal would you
rather work for the guy that's written a
book
on what his business does or the guy who
hasn't so i want to encourage you
like by writing a book even if you want
to work in corporate america or work at
a job or whatever you want to do
you with the book versus the person who
doesn't have one the person with the
book just has more
leverage number six getting public
speaking opportunities if you want to
get paid to speak or get booked on
stages or be invited to speak at
conferences or to get on virtual stages
what is that
podcasts webinars people's virtual
summits
people's challenges write a book it'll
open more doors
and i remember my friend michael
stelzner said that
in the past he had a filter for people
he invited in social media marketing
world
and he preferred that they had written a
book he's since updated that
now he said that they've created a
course or a big library of videos or
something on youtube or they have the
podcast why
because but really actually a course or
a book
because it means they've had to organize
their thoughts he's like if they're
going to be a good teacher a good
speaker
and they're going to speak on my stage
at social media marketing world i want
them to
like know a table of contents i want
them to have their ideas clear
and so that was one of his kind of like
filters for whether or not you made it
to his stage
in the past it absolutely can help you
get paid
speaking gigs and free speaking gigs
where you would speak for free but you
get the awareness you get the platform
you get to maybe sell your book after
you get to maybe
give a chance for people to opt in and
you can collect their information via
like getting a lead for your business
whatever you do number seven
you can reach more people with an
audiobook this my friend
sounds funny but the reason i think you
should sit down
and write a book is actually so you can
create the audiobook
why because you're listening right now
to the think marketing podcast
we are loving audio in culture today
you might be walking your dog you might
be on a commute you might be doing
chores around the house you might be
multitasking editing a video you know
whatever it is that you're doing
i'm in your air pods right i'm on your
noise canceling bows headphones right
now audio is a major movement
audio is a passive uh opportunity we
have whereas video we need to it's so
powerful of course we preach youtube but
video you gotta watch as well audio i
can listen why i do other things
and so an audiobook is this chance to
like my friend pat flynn says
scale intimacy he says podcast scale
intimacy because we get to hang out like
this in this intimate place
think about an audiobook it's not me
just freestyling off of my notes
it's actually that you've written down
like clear words and really put some
effort into it
now you're reading that and you get to
take your message
your mission your content your
frameworks and
really connect with somebody in a very
personal way
so i actually believe that it is worth
like writing a book just so you can
write an audio book and let's get into
some data
youtube secrets since march 2019 by the
way we didn't get the audiobook done
until maybe
six to eight months after the first book
came out
we have done a total of 19
819 units at the time of recording this
and the royalties
including bounties and so just to define
what that is
once you have the audiobook out you now
are
you have access to the audible bounty
program where if somebody signs up for a
free
amazon trial membership you get like
five bucks if they
sign up for a higher level you get like
ten dollars if they use one of their
credits you get a certain amount of
money if they just pay cash you get a
certain amount of money or they just use
their card
so all the bounties everything included
from under 20
000 units of the audiobook 67
311 profit collected crazy right
and so the powerful thing about that
is that it also continues to sell and it
continues to be available
on um audible and you know one of the
things to consider
is that once your book gets a little
momentum you know it starts being
recommended by other books people can
download it today
download it tomorrow that's leverage be
listening to it today be listening it to
it tomorrow
and so another huge reason that actually
this was more of a lesson and a surprise
going into it i wasn't like the
audiobook is the thing
i almost think like the audiobook is the
thing and i think that
of course the ebooks and the physical
are amazing as well but man audiobooks
are crazy
and they connect especially if you're
gonna launch a video podcast or a
podcast of some kind
or even youtube because a lot of people
listen to youtube and turn off the video
and listen to your content and so love
audiobooks and we haven't done this but
i've always wanted to
you can make parts of your audiobook
into videos like you can take the audio
file of that inspiring first chapter or
a portion of that first chapter
and use it as the voiceover of some
b-roll of what's happening of you know
of what
and we actually have some of that coming
up with a new book that we're going to
be launching in think media at the
beginning of
2022 but like you can use parts of your
audiobook
and turn them into video content just
like creating leverage above where you
have all this material you could use in
multiple different ways
that also links back to your
book number eight you get a physical
artifact in people's homes
and hands what do i mean in a digital
world
when you write a physical book that
people can purchase
or they buy at a book table at an event
or you just hand out for free
you know a lot of people say that books
are the best business card
why because people throw business cards
away and they lose them but when you
hand them a book
they're like man this is this is kind of
meaningful i need to at least take this
back to my hotel room before i throw it
away i mean
like you know what i mean like they they
literally will probably take their book
with them or they'll hand it to somebody
else somebody'll be like what's that
and then they'll be like oh you
interested in this sure
they're like yeah someone just gave it
to me like it can be passed around
transferred around
books are the best business card
referrals can happen from them because
somebody could finish reading it hand it
to somebody else
but it actually gets a physical artifact
in people's hands and homes
let's talk about branding let's talk
about impact let's talk about
in a digital world your artifact
with your name on the cover your book in
someone's house on their coffee table on
their bookshelf
in their book bag at starbucks open up
the the cover of your book being seen
in physical places that hundreds of
years from now they dig up the
archaeological runes and they say wow
here's your book
it's an artifact you know what i mean
powerful a physical artifact that can
really
impact people on and on and on number
nine it lets you
utilize the world's largest
search engine now maybe you've never
thought about this one
we talk about how youtube is
the uh second largest search engine in
the world and so what i mean by number
nine
the world's largest product search
engine and what is it
amazon.com so of course people are
looking for
information on google and youtube but
the largest search engine
for products and for buyers is
amazon.com
google and youtube are browsers if
you're on amazon.com
you're a buyer and so when you have a
book
think about it you can rank you can be
on
the largest shopping search engine
amazon.com amazon.com has over 126
million members
just in its prime loyalty program
so by getting a book you have a whole
new place of discovery sean why would
you write a book
you know a lot of the information in the
book might be on your youtube channel
that's true
but there's a whole other segment of
people who don't know you yet could
still discover you want to consume the
information in an organized and clear
way
want to experience it in a much more
well-presented way
but even just the people you're meeting
for the first time we've met
thousands of people who never knew us
before from just having our book on
amazon.com and stick around because i
actually have
two uh bonus tips after number 10 for
you as well we'll do some of the other
things on the podcast and heather will
be back on
and so i just had so much i can't i want
you to hear those so definitely listen
to the end
but let's hit number 10. and number 10
writing a book will help you scale
your business now you could imagine this
does this in a lot of maybe intangible
ways like your perceived authority and
all these types of things
but one of the things we did when we
wrote our book was we created a bonus
package like a bonus bundle of a little
clarity worksheet and a free video
training
that people could send in their receipt
from amazon
and then their name and email and then
we would hook them up with that free
stuff
well just from that alone we had almost
4 000 people claim the book bonuses
which means basically 4 000 contacts 4
000 in business
leads that are that much more interested
in going deeper with you
additionally we had a link to one of our
free classes towards the end of the book
and beyond that there is no question
that this book has generated
over a million dollars like that we
could verifiably track
and arguably probably two three times
more than that
intangibly from the brand lift brand
awareness
and it helps you bring in new business
even from the thing we do
business with people we know like and
trust and so by writing
a book it accelerated all of those
things and had a huge
impact on not only just my business
our youtube channels across our various
brands because someone comes on the
youtube channel hey
should i listen to this person should i
stick around and listen to this and when
you have that introduction hey
i'm the author of remember a lot of
times on youtube you're not just talking
to people who already know you
you're talking to people who are just
meeting you for the first time so you're
asking how can i accelerate trust
and so can you accelerate trust in a
sentence
well possibly for some that are viewing
they hear
oh you're the number one bestselling
author or you're you know the author of
authoritative title of your book that
reinforces the topic with which you
teach
that's going to actually just help
accelerate trust of course you got to
back it up
of course you got to follow up with
great content but that's a huge
key to scaling your business
and i'm excited in just a moment to
share the final two bonus reasons
with you well those are the first 10
lessons that sean
learned when writing the book youtube
secrets and if you think you're ready to
write your book
what are you waiting for go to start
startyourbook.live where you're going to
learn how to go from blank page
to publish author in 90 days with sean
cannell and chandler bolt from self
publishing school
in this free class you're going to learn
how to find your book idea
and the three three-step system to write
publish and launch your book you can
sign up today at startyourbook.live
now if you're loving this type of
content make sure you share it with a
friend
and make sure that you like and
subscribe wherever you're consuming this
content from
when you are over on apple make sure you
leave a review and we'll share it here
on
the podcast today's review comes from
coco cola 94
great value this podcast consistently
provides amazing
value one negative wisdom i learned in
the last episode
was to do for one what you wish you
could do for all oh that was such a
great tip
even though you can't always make a
personal connection with every one of
your viewers
each connection you have time to make is
a valuable one well thank you so much
coca-cola 94 for leaving that review and
if you've not left a review yet please
let us know what your takeaway was
from today's episode now sean promised
you two more tips so let's get back into
the content
all right welcome to the bonus two
reasons i don't think we've ever done
this before in the think marketing
podcast but i just
had to include these because i'm super
passionate about writing a book and i
realized
this might not be for everybody but i
want to encourage you i think you should
really write a book like you should
really consider
and it might not be immediately it might
not even be in the next six months or 12
months
but even just put it on your to-do list
put it on yes i want to
organize my calendar my schedule and at
the right time
i want to write the right book because
it'll trigger the right results
in my brand my business my youtube
channel and my online authority overall
so number 11
out of the total 12 reasons that will
land the plane on here
is it'll help you build your brand i've
kind of already said that so what do you
mean by that sean well
you know this is a think marketing
podcast we talk a lot about marketing we
talk about sales like generating more
revenue
there's a difference between marketing
and branding
right like a lot of times when i think
about marketing in sales i
i question what are the sales today sean
like what are the measurable
sales like i can't pay my mortgage
with my brand i can't buy a starbucks
coffee
with my brand like i i need the money i
need the actual tangible money well
that's sales and marketing
you know that's the over 200 000 or or
nearly a quarter million dollars the
book directly has generated
right when i think about branding though
branding is that more
intangible brand lift that happens
from writing a book you know a brand is
what people think about when they think
about you
a brand is how people feel branding is
an experience
and so one of the things i think the
powerful things about a book
is people seeing youtube secrets seeing
the red cover seeing the whole
brand lift is it's kind of like number
one like your authority
but like the overall brand it's lifted
the perception
of video influencers on my channel with
benji it's lifted the perception
of think media it's lifted the
perception of sean cannell the brand has
been
strengthened of sean cannell and this is
sometimes less trackable
but it's more important for longevity i
think it's important to write a book and
consider writing a book
and what i've seen from writing a
bestselling book is that
i am seeing a compound value
in my brand and one of the best ways to
brand yourself in a market and stand out
more
is by having a book that plants you
with authority around your topic and
then finally number 10 12
is legacy is legacy you know if you
haven't seen episode one definitely
check it out where
we talk with chandler bolt who's gonna
be on that free training we're doing
soon or
i think you could check out the replay
uh at the the link in the show notes or
i believe startyourbook.live
but chandler talked about some people
want to write a book maybe you don't
have business ambitions
or even if you have business ambitions
with your book either way writing a book
is legacy
a book can outlive you a book is
meaningful to your family
you become a published author like you
you you have
an artifact that can be passed down from
generation to generation
who even knows if your family will read
it but just having that book
is that piece of history it's that piece
of
legacy taking the time to write down
your thoughts
and the cool thing is again you might
even be like i don't even know if it's a
business thing it might be more of a
memoir
or maybe even non or fiction or these
different types of things
i could see the power of writing a
nonfiction book a fiction book
a memoir no matter what legacy
legacy something that could be passed
around maybe you don't want to reach
100 000 units with your book maybe you
just want to reach
100 people of your cousins and friends
and family and your children's children
like
legacy so i encourage you 12 reasons
consider writing a book and there's a
couple ways to go about it right there's
you could go out on your own uh we have
that free class you know chandler's got
more training we'll talk about other
ways to do it and
there's lots of different ways to do it
but commit to the process and commit to
quality don't just put out
you know an ebook that's 22 pages
a cover from microsoft paint and is is
just kind of
you know a half effort but really think
about
putting out something substantial yes
it's going to take more energy
but we've been benefiting now for over
three
years disproportionate value
writing this book youtube secrets with
benji one of the hardest things i've
ever done
but actually absolutely probably one of
the best things i've ever done do i
regret it are you kidding
was there times i wanted to quit
absolutely but on the other side of it
and it hasn't stopped there's momentum
still on the book will that happen to
everybody not necessarily
but whether you sell 100 copies a month
years later or even one copy a month you
still have leverage my friend
consider writing a book remember it's
not easy
but it's gonna be worth it
[Music]
you